in just three days President Trump is
set to meet North Korean dictator Kim
Jong Hyun for the first-ever summit
between the two nations the meeting will
take place at a hotel on an island in
Singapore and there is hope it could
begin the process of denuclearizing the
Korean Peninsula and formally ending the
Korean War
for some insight on what is ahead we are
joined by former New Mexico Governor and
UN Ambassador Bill Richardson he's led
several diplomatic engagements with
North Korea and joins us from Woods Hole
Massachusetts ambassador Richardson
welcome thank you nice to be with you
you've been to North Korea eight times
you've been called the North Korea
troubleshooter so what would you like to
see happen in this meeting
well besides significant progress on
denuclearization I think that is key I
don't think the North Koreans are going
to agree to totally denuclearize they've
got 60 nuclear weapons I'd like to see
progress on to other fronts one in the
area of a peace treaty in the area of a
security guarantee for North Korea but
also in the area of human rights I'd
like to see some progress on getting the
remains of our soldiers from the Korean
War back to their families I'd like us
to help the Japanese on the abduction
issue many abductees from North Korea
I'd like us to see just the general
normalization of relations in other
words exchanging liaison offices
hotlines ways that our countries can't
have a tripwire or a negative domino
effect of a conflict easing of tensions
between North and South Korea and Japan
Japan's been left out I know that's a
long list but all of that is achievable
governor the question that many have is
will this meeting be just a
meet-and-greet or will there be
something substantial that comes out of
it I guess my question is regardless of
how it ends up isn't it already a win
for North Korea because they are being
given a seat at the table with the most
powerful nation on earth and they will
say it's because they have a nuclear
capability now
well every time I've negotiated with the
North Koreans they always say we're the
big guys in the region North Korea in
the US not Japan not China not anybody
else so yes they have gotten a
significant consent from us by just
appearing at the summit but I think that
we need to do more than just a photo op
and I do think there are a number of
areas on the nuclear side on the missile
side where there will be some
achievements where there will be some
easing of tension and I mentioned
normalizing relations between the two
countries the u.s. and North Korea you
know I I applaud president Trump's going
to North Korea finding this summit
taking place I worry about us not being
prepared I worry about going for busts
saying full denuclearization I know the
North Koreans they're not going to fully
denuclearize they are very relentless
they are focused they never say no and
and my hope is that the president and
Kim Jong moon find a way to talk to each
other off the sidelines just the two of
them find a way to build some trust
because that's very big for the North
Koreans and I think the president needs
to move beyond the talking points and
the rhetoric and and build a
relationship with this man who is still
very unpredictable
your last book how to sweet-talk a shark
so you know what it is like and what it
takes to negotiate with people that may
be unpredictable and we have to in this
meeting what's the key to the
negotiation then here well I think it's
building that personal relationship I
think the president got to realize that
the North Koreans they don't think like
we do they don't believe in quid pro
quos they believe in the cult of
personality all power emanates from
their leader and you know to simply
trade like a real estate their reality
show is not going to happen it's going
to take time so I think if he doesn't
have too many expectations and finds
ways to build the process of negotiation
that may take two to three years but
have very very strong inspections
transparency in any agreement for them
to declare where their nuclear sites are
in their missile sites I because they
hide them yeah they hide them they don't
tell you where they are
so that needs to happen ambassador I
don't mean to cut you off we are out of
time but it is the first step as you
said of a long path that may be ahead
ambassador Richardson thank you very
much for the time CBS News will cover
the Singapore summit beginning with our
Sunday broadcasts we'll have updates
throughout the meeting Jeff Glor will
anchor the CBS Evening News from
Singapore on Monday and Tuesday